csináltunk az az hogy rengeteg rendszert
vezetünk be kezdve attól hogy a gyerekek
hova veszik le a ruhájukat honnan veszik
fel tehát én a szekrényük el van
rendezve mindenkinek megvan me hol van
és akkor oda teszik helyre és onnan
veszik ki meg a rendszerhez
hozzátartozik hogy ki miért felel és mit
csinál például az egyik amit leveszel a
vállamról és nem győzök elég hálás lenni
érte az a az a szennyes logisztika tehát
a ruhalogisztika hogy hogyan kerül a
tiszta ruha be a sz az egy komplex
rendszer és te cserébe kértél pár dolgot
például az egyik az hogy legyen
szárítógépodé mert ha nincs szárítógép
ennek a praktikus hozadéka vagyis a a a
a hátulütője az az hogy egyfolytában
kiló kint lógnak a valahol a ruhák és és
kell kerülgetni őket és nem eztéán ké
hozzájuk nyúlni igen mert egyszer
kiteríted és után össze és és akkor úgy
döntöttünk hogy belefektetünk egy
szárítógépbe meg ez egy példa
gyakorlatilag de ehhez hasonló tudatos
rendszert kellett hozzunk jó pár ahhoz
hogy élhető legyen a a világunk igen
nyáron mikor kiköltözünk akkor a
gyerekek mosogatnak ami nagyon jót tesz
nekik igen felelősséget vállalnak é igen
eg sikerélményt ad hogy ezt meg tudják
tenni igen amit rengeteget kellett
harcoljunk tehát nem nem nem ment ez kön
nem ment könnyen de most hogy már be van
járatva rendkívül nagy segítség